Hey, what's up guys
We Are Back
With A New Video
Now, in yesterday's experiment,
I tried turning ocean water into
Hydrogen and Chlorine Gas, and it was a fail,
and we found out that it's because I was using copper electrodes
That It Didn't Work, The Electrodes Need To Be Carbon Only
But I  Know That This Experiment Can Work  And I Don't Wanna Give Up Yet
Sometimes The Simplest Method Is The Best
So Today We're Gonna Modify This Setup A Little Bit
And See If We Can, In Fact, Extract Chlorine Gas
From Ocean Water
So This Thing Right Here Is The Modified System In A Nutshell
And You're Gonna See It's Very, Very Simple
All i Did Is Heat Up A Screwdriver With A Flame
Until It Get Hot Enough That I Can Poke
Two Holes In The Bottom Of This Plastic Container
Just Big Enough For The Carbon Rods
Once The Carbon Rods Are Pushed Most of The Way In
And I Mix A Batch Of Five Minute Epoxy
And I Put Liberal Amount Inside And Outside
Because We Need this Thing Completely Water Tight When It's Standing Upright
We're Gonna Keep Two Holes That We Made In The Container From Yesterdays Experiment
Now All We Have To Do Is Fill This Thing Backup With More Fresh Sea Water
And Attached Some Jumper-cables To The Bottom
And Let It Run
K Guys Update, Its The Moment Of Truth
I've Been Down Into The Ocean And I Got Some Fresh Ocean Water
I Filled A Container, and I've Hooked it Up to My Car Battery
All Is Left Do Right Now Attached Red Jumper-Cable lead To The Battery Terminal
And See If This Thing Actually Works
Alright So Here We Go, Moment Of Truth Let's Make The Connection
Boom
Assuming Everything Is Connected Properly Here
we should be generating chlorine gas off of the left side
and hydrogen gas off of the right side
but, there's not a whole lot of voltage
or amperage so, we're just gonna have to
let this thing hang out and i'll probably
start the car and let the alternator pick up some of the load
(engine starts up)
(music)
alright, another update
I  have come out after about an hour, and i hadn't noticed much gas production
and I think that's because the necks of the bottles
were flat against the bottom
so there wasn't much way for electricity to flow
through the solution so i just used a couple
of rocks and i propped these bottles up a little bit
and then that allows the solution to conduct the electricity to conduct the electricity
a little bit quicker, and since then
my rate of production on these gasses have gone way up
and if we check this now, you can see
that bottle is almost completely full of hydrogen
so now we got a full bottle of hydrogen, lets light it off
yeah, its good test
so i built another contraption that will help us work with smaller quantites
a little bit faster
so this here, is a much, much simpler set up
you can see i'm only running carbon electrode through the side
into a much smaller bottle
and that's because the limiting factor here is the amount of salt
that's actually in our sea water
as the chlorine is extracted
it'll get collected in this bottle
so by using a smaller bottle
the concentration of chlorine that we end up with should be higher
smell this one over here and tell me what it smells like
smells like pool water
hot tub
a hot tub
it's been over three hours now
and you can see most of the solution has been pushed out of the bottle
displaced with the gas
this should be chlorine gas and looking at it
you can see its kinda got a brownish yellow tinge to it
so there's a good possibility that we do actually have chlorine
Boom
Finally 4 and a half hours of effort but we finally got it
so here we have a little soda bottle filled with chlorine gas
Chlorine is some awesome stuff because it can be used as a disinfectant for treating and sanitizing drinking water
but it is a very dangerous chemical, you dont want to breathe this stuff in, it can do some nasty damage to you
(Inhales)
If u look in side there u should be able to see a hazy yellowish brown cloud
And that appears to me to be chlorine
so i think we have done it
i don't have any use for chlorine gas right now
but i think its really cool that we can make if we need to
the thing that really blows my mind is that salt water is very tame
but if you pump a little electricity through it
you can make some pretty vicious chemicals
Whooo! Ugh ugh...
Wow, that's powerfull!
It stings the nose, stings the throat...
Burns the lungs, I think we got ourselves some good chlorine there guys!
Mark, my brother just arrived!
Here, take that buddy!
I just want you to sniff in that hole (xD) and tell me what you smell
Smells nice!
Smells like chlorine!
Smells clean?
Smells very clean, smells like a swimming pool!
Chlorine is 2x heavier than air, so if you hold on to that and if I take my hand of the top...
The chlorine should stay in the bottle.
Now, if you want to very very carefully...
Smell in there...
Tell me if that's chlorine or not.
WHOAAOW!
Oh that is VERY strong!
It burned my nostrils!
With a little sniff?
YEAH!
Oh my gosh that is strong!
Yeah it's crazy huh?
AAAAW!
YEAH!
That hurts!